optimal room at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking so now I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue or medical
facility this episode is brought to you
by 99designs I've used 99designs for
years for all sorts of graphic design
needs whether you need a logo website
cover anything else 99 designs was
created to make great designs accessible
to everyone and to make the process of
getting designs much much easier so when
I first started out for instance testing
prototype covers and getting prototype
covers for the 4-hour body
I want to contest route that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other time zones other countries can
also help you solve that problem since
then I've worked with 99 designs on a
separate path or a different option and
that is the one-to-one project service
so in a number of cases and I'll give
you one example when I wanted to create
the cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied
they like it iterate provide feedback on
all this stuff and I haven't shared it
yet but we also got some incredibly good
really some of the best illustrations
I've ever seen from using this
one-to-one project service with a
handful of different designers and
illustrators it blew my mind 99 designs
makes this all very easy and efficient
so you can check out the Tao of Seneca
design and other work that I and your
fellow listeners for that matter have
done on 99 designs at 99 designs dot-com
forward slash Tim and right now you can
get a free 9 million dollar upgrade on
your first design again that's 99
designs dot-com for slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by trunk
club there are two types of men out
there you know who you are guys who love
shopping for clothes but are short on
time category a and those of you who
hate it
category B I am in the latter category
my fashion sense is also probably
somewhere between homeless and confused
with a dash of lazy added in either way
you can take heart and I've used trunk
club now and have found some of my
favorite pieces of clothing that make me
look a lot better than I'd be able to
handle on my own and there are many
reasons for that but you can get
clothing that fits perfectly and looks
amazing without ever stepping into a
store again thanks to trunk club and
they make it very very easy and the
clothing is handpicked by a personal
stylist your own personal stylist all
you have to do is go to trunk club comm
forward slash Tim type in your
measurements share your likes and
dislikes they'll pick your clothes from
more than 80 top brands and ship them
right to your door you keep what you
like you send back what you don't if you
don't like any of it send it all that
doesn't matter and trunk club is not a
subscription service this is what
appealed to me among many other things I
didn't want to constantly be getting
dinged by things or have to deal with
the headache of constantly getting boxes
it's not a subscription service shipping
is always free and you have five days to
try on the clothes so a couple points
here number one get started today go to
trunk club com forward slash Tim try it
out you get premium clothes expert
advice no work no risk that is a winning
combo and I have found some of my
favorite espadrilles shoes from them
bright green I do like the color green
and they actually work I've had so many
compliments on these shoes and more
people asking where I got them any other
pair of shoes I've ever had and more
shirts I kept end up keeping about I
would say three quarters in my box which
I did not expect to do so go to trunk
club comm forward slash Tim and check it
out
hello boys and girls welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I am
sitting in a hotel room overlooking the
High Line in New York City because I was
here for something called vulture fest
what is that well it was a very
important event for the world of
television entertainment film and so on
alongside others like for instance the
TCAs
the Television Critics Association and
I'm mentioning this because it's related
to today's guest of course my job is to
deconstruct world-class performers to
pick out lessons and habits and favorite
books and so on that you can use in your
own life and the guest today is Vince
Vaughn many of you know Vince of course
doesn't need a lot of introduction but
he is one of the most prolific actors
writers and producers in the world he's
acted in more than 30 major motion
pictures that have gone on to gross more
than 1.7 billion at the box office
he is largely credited for redefining
the r-rated comedy with his performance
in the 2005 hit wedding crashers which
set the record for highest grossing
r-rated comedy at the time and he is and
will continue to be I expect one of the
most sought-after leading men in
Hollywood his handprints have been put
outside the Chinese Theater and I know
of many things that are irons in the
fire that you will be seeing in the
fourth coming months and years with
Vince and one of them involves me Vince
has listened to this podcast he reached
out to me along with his production
company wild west to do a TV show
together and it is out right now
starting May 30th 2017 it is called
fearless
let's fear less in parentheses with Tim
Ferriss because the objective is to
teach you to fear less not to be
fearless big big difference between
those two and I could not be more
excited there are 10 episodes it is on
an incredible set with a live audience
surrounding us we use video we use
images in some cases live demonstrations
on stage and as of May 30th you can
watch the first episode
which is with David Blaine master
illusionist and endurance artist for
free at att.net so check that out for
free and fo show you should take a look
at this episode of David Blaine people
meaning you guys have asked me for so
long for David Blaine and now you can
see him live performing magic getting
into his personal stories at att.net so
look for fearless with Tim Ferriss and
you can find it on that home page and
all of the rest of the episodes you will
be able to find as they're released on
DirecTV if you have DirecTV or want
DirecTV and you can then stream them on
DirecTV now dot-com and there is a free
trial option that you check out so there
are no reasons not to take a look and
some of you have asked for instance and
I've seen these on Twitter in the last
couple of weeks you know I buy one of
your books and give you 12 bucks every
three years but I've had benefits for 10
years that doesn't seem fair what should
I do
well if you want to spend just a few
bucks after watching the first episode I
would really appreciate it and you can
check out the entire season of fearless
so that is that we cover so much in this
conversation with Vince and get into
stories of his early beginnings how to
negotiate his cold calling career as it
were at least a few jobs that
contributed to that and the many of the
most important decisions that he made as
a producer as an artist as a
businessperson and entrepreneur for
instance I really had a blast doing this
I hope you enjoy it as much as I did and
please check out fearless with Tim
Ferriss you can also find the trailer
and other things at Tim blog forward
slash fearless and again the entire
episode for David Blaine can be found at
HTT as always thank you for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
all right thank everyone for coming it
but we're missing half of the show here
so without further ado let's bring out
Vince Vaughn
I look a lot shorter in person
it feels very intimate and comfortable
the white room with the skateboard ramp
we will be doing a skateboarding
demonstration afterwards which is why we
have the curb background thank everybody
for coming this is going to be a fun
conversation Vince and I have had a
chance to spend a good amount of time
together we are going to delve a lot
into his story many of his decisions and
adventures some of which I think you
will have not heard before certainly
many of which I will have not heard
before and I thought we would just start
with a little bit of context so this
show is something that I have in some
form or another wanted to do for a very
long time and we connected initially
through the podcast so I thought maybe
if you would want to give a little bit
of background as to how we connected how
this came together sure and then I'll
switch gears and we'll go right I was
I'm a fan of Tam's and I really
appreciated the books as well as the
podcast his investigations into things
and finding ways to effectively get past
your trepidations or fears and become
able to engage in things in a way that
was more fulfilling so I liked his whole
journey in this and the way that he
approached it so I thought it was like
the Warren Buffett of producers and then
I really liked to just engage in things
that I'm excited about or that I really
enjoy because you do end up spending
quite a bit of time on it so as a fan
and someone that was enjoying it I
reached out to Tim and said if this
feels like a compliment to what you're
doing and still not taking from what
you're doing is there a version of doing
this where we kind of record it with
people that feels like a good
continuation and I reference your TED
Talks specifically the dealing with fear
and you're vulnerable experience is
younger with some pretty traumatic
experiences and how that instead of
suffocating you or maybe it did at the
time how later in life you were able to
riad ress those
it's part of the reason that I'm excited
to talk to you in front of all these
folks because we're going to get into
some of those moments for you certainly
and it's a portion of life that is very
often glossed over and that people don't
see when they idolize people on the
magazine covers and they assume that
they're flawless and that perhaps as a
result you as a normal are in some way
uniquely flawed and instead wanting to
showcase how people can succeed despite
the weaknesses and pain that they might
have experienced or developed over time
so let's go way way back and talk a
little bit about childhood I figured
that'd be a good place to start
how would you describe your childhood
where did you grow up
well that's age 37 my hair started to
get lighter again returning back but uh
my parents my both my parents came from
single moms and both came from very
economically challenged backgrounds and
so they really had a real aspiration to
give a better opportunity to their kids
and so I was around a great work ethic I
had an interesting journey in that
originally we started off a very humble
means and my father was very
self-motivated and was very successful
started his own business and did very
well and then as I got older we moved
into more affluent area and had exposure
to you know public schools with good
schools and all of those kinds of things
but I think it informed me where I had a
work ethic I didn't put a big focus on
results meaning finances were never a
driving factor not that I was raised
that you had to take care of yourself
but being good or working hard to
something what was valued so I think I
was fortunate to have make you do a lot
what your parents do versus what they
say so I was fortunate to have a good
role models in that way what was your
dad's business let's have a business my
dad well my dad his dad worked and is
still known on a real Road and had a
small little hundred acre farm but he
cooked on the and the factory and I said
keep the farm going and his mom and dad
were divorce legal in the summers at the
farm and he was the first in his
immediate family there to go to college
so he was a Salesman he wanted to make a
living so he started off the Swift Meat
Company and selling stuff and then he
ended up in toys so as a kid it was a
great profession because we always had a
lot of toys he had sample toys I'd get
in trouble because I'd go get him and
start playing with the needs you can't
touch that that's like it's merchandise
merchandise yeah but it was odd because
they would argue and do business in the
way that you would in the industry but
the comedic part to me was they were
arguing over a ninja turtle you got to
put those damn Ninja Turtles on the
[ __ ] shelf you know in but it was I
found it kind of like I was watching
casino but they were talking about they
were talking about Evel Knievel stunt
cycle but he was a manufacturer's rep so
what and would be sort of an agent they
would represent the manufacturers
getting them shelf space and you know
Kmart or Toys R Us retail so he'd be
selling to the retailers correct correct
what made him good at that
we're going to get into your ability to
pitch no but my dad sure thing because
my dad is maybe the most honest person
he's overly bright but I think he just
can connect and relate with people I
think he genuinely is empathetic with
people um I would see him in deals
sometimes like with a house transaction
and people put town money and it didn't
go through but my dad would always give
him their money back he was interesting
that way so I think people trusted him
and felt comfortable with him and the
long run I think it really and out for
him because he he wasn't as focused on
that stuff but he great sense of humor
and good sense of humor about himself
but I think he was very is still very
you know engaged with people one thing
that struck me when we very first had
dinner this was a while back and this is
actually something a few of my friends
who have now I met you on set when we
were filming have mentioned is that you
ask a lot of questions which
I hate to say it but it's been unusual
for me in my experience with say
entertainment and you're very enquiring
and I think that helps to build an
empathy is that something that you
developed at home did you develop it
some other way I think I was always
curious about things and interested in
people and I like to learn and be
challenged on stuff so I don't mind I
like to ask stuff and again as I said my
journey with you started really being a
fan of what you were doing but I was
also I was very inspired by the
background that led to you to this
experience because I'm interested in
that that some very challenging things
led to this beautiful life but there's
others who could have had those things
and it could have been crushing to them
and I find what you do to be an olive
branch and give some skills to others
could they be choose the good life and
not be defined by the challenges and I
think that's empowering the people so I
like that so for the people who don't
have the context here the TED talk that
I gave that Vince was referring to
talked about a number of different
challenges I had including a late
lifelong fear of swimming so I didn't
learn to swim and tell us in my 30s
which is embarrassing for a Long Island
boy and the story has to what led to
that well I was there are many different
components but the supposed primary
catalyst was a summer camp experience I
have not as a very little kid I was a
runt and generally stayed away from the
playground because that was a danger
zone for me it's where you just get your
ass kicked those my association is not
for play and when summer camp and kids
were diving off this dock through an
inner tube which looks like fun I did
that and a bully of the camp grabbed me
by the ankles as I went through I tried
to come up and get air and kept hitting
my back on the bottom of the inner tube
and just thought I was going to drown
because I couldn't get my head above
water
and ultimately fortunately somebody
spotted that he was a counselor and I
didn't die obviously I'm here but that
led me to never want to swim period
even though I was right next to the
water and I suppose this is a good point
is I need to ask you about because you
and I actually haven't really spoken
about this but but then later in life
you evaluated it differently not being
the child emotionally in that moment
right later
later I had a number of people who were
very instrumental in helping me to
rethink swimming and also to not
denigrate it so I had I had rationalized
not being able to swim by dismissing it
as unimportant and at one point one of
my close friends
first of all said this is a life skill
you need to have for you and for your
kids so I'm assigning a open water race
to you by the end of this year is your
new year's resolution Oh Mike oh I
didn't realize that was up to another
person to decide and he's very or he was
at the time addicted to stimulants
meaning like eight double espressos a
day so I said alright if I'm going to
learn to swim which is the scariest
thing in the world to me you can't have
anything stronger than green tea for a
year and if you agree to that I'll do
the open water swim and I didn't think
he'd do it he said deal and so that was
the stakes and then someone helped me to
rethink how to go about the swimming in
a step-by-step fashion and but it was
that initial pain that initial
experience that later led to rethinking
swimming which then led to rethinking a
lot of things and it's led to the show
among other things and so half of me
that very story was a great entry into
engaging and hearing yourself and how
you dissect things and the people that
were getting up and sharing because I
think on some level we all are looking
for those things in life how to let go
of stuff and how to enjoy things in a
more productive way could you talk about
your car accident in high school sure
yeah that's something that we've talked
about no I'm going to talk about it much
what we were it was after school I had
played sports and and I had stopped I
started getting more into acting and it
was during the day and I was a passenger
and it was raining out and the girl that
was drive
being was swerving on the road being
cute
remember saying don't swerve don't don't
you know stop it but she kept doing it
we were going maybe 35 miles an hour and
then we hydroplane and I woke up in a
ditch my thumb ripped up real bad and I
couldn't move my legs couldn't move
I had paramedics over me and I have
blood all around me I was real concerned
by a friend I didn't have any idea how I
looked I wasn't tracking it my friend
was real bloody I said it Shawn okay
they said yeah he's alright they got me
an ambulance and then they couldn't get
ahold of my parents at first as they
were worth traveling and so remember
being in a lot of pain there was a
moment you didn't know what the
ramifications were I had a small
compression which turned out to be
nothing in my back but and the aesthetic
of my thumb being injured at the time I
didn't mean it's now just a very bad
scar on the back side of it and
thankfully I have the thumb and can move
it but there's a pad that was gone so
that was um that was challenging because
it really made me evaluate the oldest
cliched you know without your health you
don't have anything so I really got the
experience of feeling like well what if
I can't move around or people go outside
and play and things I had taken for
granted
and then this the anything physical that
is different that you're used to in a
certain way I think at first its natural
to feel insecure about it and here I was
at that time knowing one to pursue being
an actor entertainer so it was a gift in
you know processing things and putting
your focus on other things and you
started to realize the power of your own
inner dialog far as what you were
creating or not so there was a lot of
gifts in it ultimately but at the time
it was I feel lucky for it and that it
was without real consequences it was a
it was a nice learning gift in a way
just to we're going to talk a lot about
that inner dialogue and self-talk but I
don't want to touch on a few things that
are around that same time period and as
maybe a preface to that I will say that
Vince is one of the most consistently
curious people I've ever met a lot so my
job is to interview curious people and
give you an idea we were just backstage
getting miked up and he had questions
about something called the Marcelo team
so Marcelo team is a joke that's used in
Brazilian Jujitsu by the Michael Jordan
/ Wayne Gretzky of grappling his name is
marcelo garcia so I was backstage
choking Vince about ten minutes ago and
there are a lot of very nervous looks
very effectively I want a good choke
Zola knows what he's doing and grappling
was one of the first things wrestling
specifically that we bonded over mmm and
could you talk about the role of sports
and wrestling to the extent that it's
that had a lasting impact I think it's
important I think you know George
Washington I think credited ballroom
dancing and horseback riding is two of
the most important things he did because
it gave him confidence physically in
grace and you know being a leader I
don't know that you can put grace in the
body without you know whether it's I
took ballets and took play sports I
think it's important especially for me
being tall it allowed me to have I think
more control and confidence in my and my
um my high ten and so wrestling to me
was really a course in resiliency and
discipline I would have loved to fight
other team sports but it was I was very
good at wrestling for whatever reason
and I wasn't as accepted and some of the
team sports so wrestling is very much a
loner sport if you're on a team bus you
kind of joke around and laugh on a
wrestling bus everyone is dead side over
partially because they're all dehydrated
from cutting away cutting weight and
you're going to get in a fight in front
of your school or people you don't know
it's like you shake hands and it's like
you're going you know there's no one
missed a block you got that beanie right
and you are dehydrated it's added and
that you're growing and yet you're
trying to maintain a weight as I mean
it's especially when you're doing it
when you're younger it's very
challenging but I really felt that I got
and this you know you would come out of
playing football feeling like you were
in shape and then you would go and
wrestling and you would realize you're
not in any kind of shape because if you
just wrestle it's exhausting and then
the only other thing you can do is run
and in the winter in Illinois that meant
hallways and stairs we had a coach it
was he got fired he was not fit to be
with kids but I I felt like I was I
benefited from having that personality
but he was a real problem but I remember
feel like we needed a little more
elaboration so people's minds don't go
crazy well he was he was he was uh he
had a real anger problem he would hit
okay he just I got hit this isn't
spotlight I just want him yeah he
punched me once in the chest after a
match it went out of me he would he
encouraged kids hurting each other but
if he normal at the time you know he was
like the Cobra Kai yeah he was like
Cobra Kai it was crazy he had his own
emotional issues so we would win a meet
like 62 six or whatever it was and he
would be angry over the few mistakes and
he would it was at some point you just
for the emotion being poured on you
remember his sister was an assistant
he'd always say get me a tab in an
aspirin or an advil Oh give me my
cooking at abhinash advil and he keeps
screaming at us but he would sometimes
like there was a you know we would run
these stairs and he would say in these
hallways it was it was like a spread but
he didn't make it under a minute 20 you
would add another one right he was
intentionally you were going to have the
bar moved and he was trying to break
your spirit he wanted to simulate all is
lost what you thought was going to get
you there is not and not will you stand
right but inevitably the second-string
heavyweight was never going to make that
time so the first time he would do it
he's okay he called the kid's name out
loud was a Illinois's he
it was I remember the name I won't say
it might have been like Eastern European
last name and he said he was late so
then the first time you'd run after that
there'd be some encouragement come on
you could do it but the second or third
time kids would start yelling and
screaming at him or kicking at him and
really physically forcing him was like a
buck a bad bad a few good men yeah it
was terrible and I always had a problem
with the third Authority anyway and I
clash with him a lot I ended up just
showing up at the meets and I was good
enough that I could do that I wouldn't
go to practices all the time I really
had problems with them he did punch me
one time in the chest but he turned out
to be someone that created a past that
was not truthful he had told us that he
made the Olympic team but that it was
when a year that we boycotted it it
turned out not to be true you know but
anyway I guess the long version of it is
I think that I gained all more than I
lost even with him being challenging in
a lot of ways I wouldn't change that
experience and you can have a great
coach which there are in wrestling and I
think in general one of the great
attributes of wrestling is Constitution
and grit the ability to survive painful
moments and not take them on in the
absolute sense meaning to have
perspective on pain well I want touch on
the word grip for a second because
there's there are many researchers who
have looked at grit and written about
Angela Duckworth being one of them there
are many others and also for instance I
think it's Carol Dweck you wrote a book
called mindset she talks about these are
intrinsic versus extrinsic validation
and kids and so you're talking about
your your dad focusing on process and I
think that helps you to develop grit and
because you don't assume you're a
failure if you have an isolated say
failure on the mat as long as you're
putting in the process that allows you
to persist which I think it relates to a
lot of your career but I want to talk
about maybe not the beginning of your
career because it's different but shitty
jobs when you're young because one other
person that had for instance on the
podcast Chris Sacca I've watched go from
having a tough time affording a place in
Truckee just like a mountain cabin -
being on the cover of the Forbes - issue
now well-known billionaire investor and
one of his criteria for evaluating
people to invest in is have they had
shitty jobs or not like he likes to see
people who have had should each service
shot I was a busboy got abused on Long
Island for a long time are any
particular do any particular jobs come
to mind I had a few of them younger and
service industry in that but the one
that was I changed perspective on as it
got old or was it seemed great at the
time but I'm sure that before but was
the telemarketing job I was old enough
to drive a car it was 16 it was the
summertime we were always encouraged you
know working so I got a job I thought it
was a great job cuz i sat behind this
desk and I would read this you know form
and insert names and I kind of make it
my own and I like competition and it
felt as such than that we would all be
in a room together and it was an odd
setup looking back it was a guy anyone
15 years older than you seems old that's
just how life is
so he felt old to me although he was
probably younger than I am now but he
had a very young much younger girlfriend
she would bring him soup and they'd sit
in the back office it was an odd arrange
but we would sit at this table and and
we would fell in the name would be on
the board now what we were selling was
the point that came in question years
later because it was a nondescript
building in Waukegan Illinois referred
to as walk easy Illinois but we were
selling tickets to the Lake County
sheriff's police rodeo so the fact that
the police were throwing a rodeo would
really have won suggest it was an
authentic thing because the police are
throwing a rodeo right I don't know if
the police even knew about the damn
rodeo and there was there was a family
package that was $20 which got you four
and then there was a horseman would you
like to send an orphan I mean who
doesn't want to send an orphan to an
event
was a time in the rodeo wasn't
questioned the treatment of anything
like that so I was very good at sewing
orphans so I say the family and my
family is not going to make it I said
what would you like an orphan to go for
five dollars you can give an orphan a
chance to go why I don't know how many
orphans there were in Lake County but
they and thousands of them paid for so I
was feeling great like I'm selling these
tickets to the rodeo to the sheriff's
rodeo and a nondescript building in
Illinois but I got good at calling
people you know make them laugh connect
to them in some way and then emotionally
hit him up for the orphans if it said no
the other package and that was an
interesting one because yours later at
16 I took it at face value and years
later I evaluated you know in those
moments when your your mind wanders I
started the question was there ever a
rodeo and who were these orphans and
maybe I was taking money from people on
a fixed income that didn't feel good
yeah what what was so the boiler-room
some JT Marlin aspect aside do you
remember any of the script they had the
reader and oh and so home I'm Vince
Vaughn calling from Lake County
sheriff's police rodeo and it was
something along the lines of everything
you wrote police for throwing a rodeo
and celebration as the families and I
can't make a family practice for what
would you like to send an orphan for
just five dollars an orphan can go and
enjoy the after as if like some orphans
were going to come out and the other
ones have to stay inside the place
concept I know it's crazy that you did
evaluate but I remember seeing as a
competition and I did very well
I want tickets to Madonna or something
for selling out but anyway we we get her
sitting outside and every week there was
a turnover so the bottom 20% would go
and there'd be a new 20% and some of the
people doing the job were older than I
was and I was kind of excited and look
and there was a little bit of the
factory mentality of people who weren't
so happy or excited and I learned that
it had a different perspective because
they were like that the job really meant
something to them and they didn't they
didn't want to be in the bottom
20% of the board and then I saw kind of
the you know turning on each other and
that kind of side of things as well
third place at a steak knife that's
right on a place yeah [ __ ] that's
right at one of those situations from
Adam if he knew this my first job out of
college was smiling and dialing I had to
spell via the phone in Silicon Valley is
big data storage systems and my seat was
stuck in the fire exit I couldn't even
back my chair out like no that's here Oh
what was your pitch what was that what
was your pitch
oh the pitch well the pitch my pitch was
a little bit different although these we
did network that's definitely sweetens
the deal but it was really doing my
homework on the front end because I had
to try to guess of selling the CTOs and
CEOs these large data storage systems to
places like American Airlines or
National Geographic survey I think
that's the acronym and massive at the
time was like a hundred gigabytes oh my
gosh
any buy for $50 $100 of fries now but I
would ask them I'd say I read about you
I'm calling out of left field you don't
know who I am not I'm not going to try
to make up a story but I read an article
in IT News monthly about how you did a B
and C and I found it fascinating I know
you're probably busy but I was wondering
you know are you you I assume you're
using like a Solaris system for you're a
B and C and if I'd done my homework
they'd be like I am that's a good guess
and then I say look I have to run to a
meeting of course I didn't have a
meeting that I got to run to a meeting
something like that I would love to just
send you a quick email you can feel free
to ignore it if you if you're too busy
but I'm working with the startup I think
some of the technology could be really
good fit for you and so far just yeah it
is a pickup artists approach to solve
ETS picking up CPS I'm really busy right
exactly false time constraint now yes
yeah and we're going to talk about your
phone calls a bit more soon but the map
now did you did you really believe in
what you were selling I did
I did yeah and I did there came a point
later where I didn't towards the
tail-end where I realized wait a second
like we're promising things like the
sales team is promising things my
friends were mostly an engineering group
because I had to understand the tech to
sell the way that I wanted to sell and
then a lot of the folks on the sales
team were selling stuff that had been
promised from the higher-ups that the
engineers were saying they couldn't
deliver and I said wait a second
in tech that's called vaporware and I
was like wait a minute I'm not okay
selling with vaporware that's not good
at all and that's when I started
plotting starting my own thing sure I
just didn't feel good about it sure is
it true that you became class president
because you were academically
disinclined but felt that they would
have to graduate you if you were class
president there's a lot of truth in that
statement this incline might be a strong
Burbage but at a young age I had I
developed a real problem with central
one way of doing anything and I found
myself conflict with it my entire
academic we want to call it a career so
yeah I didn't didn't put a real value I
always try to think for myself and so
there were some teachers who I quite
enjoyed and would get a lot out of it
there was others that I just really
didn't engage with and I for some reason
gave myself permission to speak my mind
and I was always I think empathetic in
that I had a lot of different
experiences and friends with different
groups and I was on all sides of it so I
got along with everybody and I was very
bored with school I didn't enjoy it I
had younger when I was very young I did
I did well on an IQ test and yet I was
not paying attention I just wasn't
didn't was bored and I remember they
took me to a psychiatrist they said oh
we think he might have learning
disabilities and I was really afraid and
I at the time I didn't vocalize it but I
was maybe six but I thought that me at
the other side of this there was a fear
that they could take me
family so I remember like overly talking
in a way that I was an expert on
everything I was saying and that I knew
the answers to things and I for whatever
reason in my young mind I felt like I
had to really nail this or they were
going to take me away and it came back
that I was borderline hyperactive but
that's emotion
boys I think like you can't sit still
you're not listening and so I had that
kind of thing in me so I always loved to
read and I always love to learn and I
just didn't like the process of
memorizing and taking tests I never
enjoyed it and I didn't enjoy stuff that
I found to be ineffective and I felt
ethically challenged with playing the
game as if like if I didn't believe
something why am i writing it should I
not be investigating a principle that
sound why am i catering to an individual
who isn't presenting a good argument and
why would I just you know try to get
their approval and play the game versus
really investigated which would lead to
confrontations and I got in a lot of
trouble I would cut school and those
kinds of things as well and so
ultimately yes I was nervous I had to
graduate high school my parents said you
got to graduate high school and it was
less I mean I had it was more about
there were certain requirements I didn't
meet I hadn't taken enough years of math
or Orla foreign language wasn't
interesting the way they were teaching
foreign language I didn't like that
we're saying to gusta for three years or
no one could speak and Spanish so I just
didn't enjoy the process of it so I
thought if i if I'm senior class
president the senior class president
will speak at graduation and I was very
opposed to anything class president I
didn't like for whatever reason I didn't
like that kind of thing it was not I
didn't most kids were running for
student council thought this is going to
look great on my application to an Ivy
League school I don't know why but that
kind of bothered me so anyway I thought
I got to do this because I got to give a
speech and they'll have to they'll have
to pass me I senior year I couldn't miss
any classes they didn't pass me I would
not have graduated and the idea of not
moving to California and pursuing what I
wanted to do which
new in the idea of having to go to
summer school was a real concern of mine
so I did run for class president I did
win class president in doing so I did
get better grades my senior year and I
think some of it was perception
interestingly enough because I was the
class president I found my grades to
improve with very little effort well you
don't wanna be the one teacher who ends
up flunking the class and I think you
look prisoner's dilemma what the other
teacher is an interesting look back at
your rationale right it was like oh this
would position me in a way that would
checkmate
we're going to pass these class it
worked perfectly yeah when did Del Close
enter the picture and could you describe
for people who that is well I started
taking I knew that I enjoyed acting and
so I started I live close to Chicago
which was a great place for training
because it wasn't as if you were going
to be on stage and go to a pilot or a
better professional opportunity it was
really just about the training so that
was excellent
I took a workshop it was called the
actors Center Shakespeare and dance and
I met a gentleman in that that said
you'd be very good at improv you might
like improv and I'm a member of a group
called the improv Olympic and I knew a
second city I said well I thought maybe
I would take classes second city said
well this guy del clothes who started
second city has since left he felt that
it's become more sketch oriented and he
started this thing called The Herald in
which it's true improvisation you learn
a set of skills you'll take suggestions
from the audience and you will
incorporate the games that you play and
hopefully crack create a linear story
structure that has an ending with the
things that are set up in the beginning
payoff and so I wasn't old enough to be
in these bars but they put me on stage
very quickly was a woman I think she
still wants a name Charla they were very
nice to me I went down and maybe after
two or three weeks they put me on stage
and I started performing it was really a
writer's workshop a lot of great writers
have have come out of that same system
because you're seeing others do it
you're having to think ahead of how
you're going to match this up and so he
was a very
guy I wasn't had taken a few classes
with him I didn't get to know him
intimately but he would always say
there's nothing funny about comedy and
you know was the stories you hear about
him kind of you know being intense about
it was very true but it was great
exposure at a young age to be given the
permission to actually perform and to do
it and to do it live in front of an
audience is it true I read that on the
first day of classes he gave he would
say there's nothing [ __ ] funny about
comedy no to the students or does that
sound like something that even though he
did he would say that and I wasn't with
him as much he had he would come in and
there was classes I took with him but it
was an interesting point of view that
you're not there to yuk it up and signal
the people that were having fun the
comedy on some level can be an over
commitment to the absurd so something
that is an extreme point of view and
your absolute commitment to that it
could be comedic right so I like that as
a foundation on some level but you were
you were taking things seriously to some
degree or putting your weight behind it
if you would and what what separated
when you were watching whether it's
fellow students or people who were more
advanced the good improv people from the
great improv people well there's there's
different body types and there's
different energies but I mean that in a
way of some people you know this in life
too right like like Jackie Gleason had
this or Farley habit and I don't mean
about size it's just a presence and then
others are more intellectualized or you
know thought-out so there's more than
one way to the waterfall there's not one
size fits all
but and you may you know you could draw
from I think that one of the great ways
to learn is watching others you don't
learn from being isolated you really
only learn from watching others in an
application to by doing it you can't
learn I think in fact it's impossible to
learn from just repeat just writing down
what someone else is saying but so it
was great in the live sense to draw from
others and to take from them but I
didn't see it much different than method
acting and that ultimately was about
listening
you had to be present in the moment for
what the other person was providing
because if you responded without hearing
it it killed the commitment from the
audience to believe it so if you said
I'm an astronaut one of the first
lessons is yes and so I would accept
what you do and add to it but if you say
we're astronauts and I say no or not
with Cowboys then the audience is now
disengaged because there's no
believability but if you say we're
astronauts and I say yes and we also
train horses how are we going to do this
I've continued the creation of the
imagination so in collaborating I think
listening is is paramount because you
you want to be working together to
create a reality so let's talk about
listening to yourself and this relates
to moving west so you done town shows at
you had a as understand at a national
commercial spot with Chevrolet that's
right and thank god you're tall enough
to be put on stage they wouldn't get
arrested immediately if you'd been a
little guy like me and that how did you
decide to go west because for instance
I've heard different trains of thought
related to this I remember hearing a
very well-known stand-up comedians say
to another stand-up comedian who's just
getting started don't move to New York
or LA until you're good I think those
are the big leagues that's we're gonna
have people in the audience who matter
like get good in the hometown and these
following places and then move to the
big city you went from what you were
doing in Chicago and then West what was
the internal conversation like how did
you think through that there was a
different mindset at the time I think in
general with young actors in that you
know I don't know that I ever thought I
would make a lot of money doing it or I
didn't have I didn't define successes
like all make a lot of money or star in
a movie and make it to me it was more I
really loved enjoying this if I could be
good in the scene I'd like that and if I
could get a chance that there was
nothing in my mind's eye that was
separate meaning a commercial or a
television show anything
a that would be performing and making a
living doing it felt like a good idea so
I had had a level of success in Chicago
I my turn should want me to do anything
professional like that I was 18 but then
I got an agent
that's a other story but I got this
agent and I started booking the national
commercial I mean silly things like
Sears Roebuck had a universal weight
machine and I would even wear the
demonstrators of how to use you know and
in Indiana farm insurance commercial
different stuff so I felt like I was
working a lot and I had trained quite a
bit I took it very seriously and I had
had trained a lot every chance I had I
was taking classes and reading so when I
went to Los Angeles
I really had a point of view that I
belong so maybe to your friends point I
at that age although of course it was a
lot more to learn and but I gave myself
that permission and I felt there the
opportunities would be greater out there
and I don't know what's in a young man's
mind for how they land on things other
than it felt like a better opportunity
and that's what I was putting my chips
anyway and I think then the
telemarketing or the sales stuff did
help because I was able to call agents
with confidence and suggests that they
should sign me and they remember them
saying we don't work with unknown people
we only work with like well-known people
as an agent at ICM and I said well no
one at my age is that well no I said I
feel really like I'm ready for this and
persisted enough that she recommended me
to a girl she knew who used to be an
assistant and it was like was next to
Pink's hot dogs it was a small little
office I got in and but it was a great I
had opportunities to audition so so you
meet with this former assistant next to
Pink's hot chocolate yes and what what
do you say in the first meeting I was
just like I'm here I didn't I'm just
there to be an actor I was there to work
and I was very self-assured in the fact
that I would work hard to do it and I
signed up for classes and I think they
just thought okay this kid seems like
he's serious but I think it's important
to know that no one talked about like
the friends I had younger
there wasn't as when he was three
networks at the time and then Fox came
around but there wasn't as much
opportunity I guess uh and people were
really invested in studying and would
talk about movies or books and you know
exploring there wasn't a focus on making
it or certainly not on leveraging
celebrity in a way of selling I've never
done a commercial or I don't think
there's if people do that there's
nothing wrong but I saw that very
different I never wanted to be in that
so it was really just you know acting
imagination exploring you know it's not
that there's anything
regal about it other than the fact that
it's a joy that you have but there
wasn't any sort of financial component
to it in fact you probably weren't going
to make a lot of money if you were going
to go into acting and I think that
served myself and my friends that there
was really focus on getting better and
learning about this and really is a gift
sort of going in and learning about
yourself ultimately which I think in
life is sort of what you come to realize
as you get older is really what the
journey is how do you do make ends meet
during that time I was very fortunate
that the Chevy commercial and it was
literally I never talked I caught some
car keys and then they would put that
into different clips $60,000 I would
made off that in the year and other
commercials I had that made a lot of
money so I was financially way ahead of
the game and I live very frugally and
then I started working and you know
you'd get residual checks and money
coming in so I was very fortunate that I
that I was a working actor at a very
young age when I say working I need not
well-known but able to to work and share
able to pay the bills yes I've heard
from a reliable mutual friend that you
used to call for instance Disneyland and
clubs to get us tickets and tables ah
early on
yes what would how did those go what was
the strategy well I had some influences
younger I had a friend that lived in a
trailer park in he his mom I remember
the first time I went to his house
there's two babies and the cribs it was
trailer-park he had and those
grandparents home and they used to
charge him a quarter to shower which I
found odd but I come to realize that the
mom had like 15 or 16 kids all by
different fathers and so I don't know
that they put a huge value sadly on
these kids and he would he was a he
would survive he would find ways to eat
or do things to survive and so I was
fascinated he could walk into places by
feeling like he belong there
he would go in a grocery store and he
would just start to make a sandwich and
eat it and talk to the people why he did
it they wouldn't bother him and he would
he would he would talk to the security
guard as he left and it was interesting
to me and we would buy liquor this way
other kids would go and spot there and
have the you know the sailors or whoever
was in the neighborhood sometimes you'd
get it sometimes you wouldn't but he
would buy like a who I would do this
later in life but it was a game to me I
think younger I thought it was like
could you get away with this but we
would buy like a loaf of bread some
mustard but then underneath the shopping
cart we would put bottles of vodka there
we weren't even old enough to be buying
the booze and you talked to everyone and
you go through the checkout line this is
before things would beep and you'd buy
your bread and your Bologna and you
would cart out you know at 18 19 years
old the vodka underneath so as it
pertained to Disneyland it was a an
actor I won't name his name but he
became very well known as successful but
I knew that the head casting director
for Disney I knew his name because I had
auditions for stuff at Disney so I
called the park on Saturday and said I'm
an assistant for this casting director
and I have a bunch of young actors who
were starring in a movie we weren't well
known as a way to plan so you're the
assistant for the casting director who's
not at work because it's a Saturday
that's right it was a Saturday no one
had cell phones and I knew his name
would be on the lists of people and I
said I worked for so-and-so
I'm his assistant and there's a movie
starring a bunch of actors we want them
to spend some time together and
we want them to come into the park and
they would say well what's your name I
say my name they say you're not on the
list I found his personal assistant I'm
not on the list but I think his name
should be on it and I'd overly like to
spell it for them and they would say yes
they say we're not sure and I said well
let me give you the list of names and I
think like really well-known actors like
really really well-known actors I say
they would love to come in so of course
they would accommodate and then and of
course once they said yes and it was
approved I would then at the end say I'd
give one name which was my real name
right which wasn't well known and then
at the end once they approved it they
were going forward I would then say you
know what put it under the unknown
person's name because the other one
probably won't want to deal with stuff
but at that point they had already
agreed so we would go and get passes and
go into the park and go on the rides and
go around and it felt like you know that
you're looking at it now as you're older
it doesn't feel good but younger there
was hair but younger getting it was
something fun about getting into a bar
when I wasn't allowed to
I liked performing more live on stage
when I wasn't supposed to be there it
was provocative to me getting alcohol
seemed fascinating or get anything in
life felt that I was not supposed to be
doing it I was drawn to and this seemed
interesting to me because it was like
getting in and it was innocent on some
level but yes we used to do that we used
to also do a lot of crank calling and I
would crank call this is before UFC was
real popular we used to crank call like
karate studios or these places and I
would make it like I was a troubled
youth who've gotten fights and I had
real issues and I beat up every one I
ever fought and I said I really need to
focus this in train and they kind of be
uncomfortable and I would tell some
really crazy stories and then I would
always suggest as I was interested in
the reaction then I would always suggest
I want to join and I want you to put me
in fights but I need to respect you so
I'm coming down to fight you we need to
lock ourselves in a room and maybe your
tricks are gonna work I call
I would say I'm an emotional dragon I
live in a place with whatever so I would
try to create a scary scenario and
sometimes they would say well you need
to fight some of my underlings and I say
I'll choose who your underlings I'm fine
give me one under lane and then I want
you but if you're going to teach me I
need to know that you can handle what I
call a real fight and I used to do it
and we would be crying but sometime I
had one guy really snap get your ass
down here he really did a promotional
thing I was like I'm bringing my attacks
down there and I would call just to see
the response I had one I used to do that
was fun with some actresses that I
worked with we would be bored on
location and so there would be these
late nights there still is you know
record and tapes you could buy or a set
of steak knives or some ab workout thing
or what have you and they would always
say these were you know whatever so I
would call and in a really long process
I would ask a lot of detailed questions
right is this and has it been tested or
are these standards yes I think these
are extraordinary hits the sound
tremendous and does it come with this
and is there nothing I could tell the
persons on coke with this guy buy it so
right at the point when I was going to
make the purchase order the actress
would pick up the phone and say herb are
you ordering something off the damn TV
again no no I'm talking to son don't get
off the phone you don't know my business
I were to jobs and herds by army of a
pile of things that herb doesn't use and
I got to pay for these things and he
better so we would create a dynamic for
the person who was selling where they
had invested a lot of time were they
going to lie and fell to her or were
they were going to listen to the
distressed wife who was paying for all
the good stuff and it was different
every time sometimes they would say yes
ma'am he is ordering again sometimes
they would go along with ice no I'm just
a friend and we're talking
so we are we were just bored and so we
were using improv or evil I guess it'd
been I would have been a fantastic
psychology professor yeah you were as I
understand it
rejected for certain roles because of
your height is that true I mean that
leading leading men at the time or that
the roles they were casting for or maybe
the people you'd be featured with would
be shorter and their issues there that
that that ended up being an issue in the
early days I think whatever you're
getting rejected for they find a reason
to say it you know I think when I was
going up for role younger and I was so
much taller than people they would say
that I'm sure it played a role into it
but I think it's important whatever
you're doing that you don't give voice
to things that you're not able to change
you would have to use it in a way to
find ways to do stuff it's all neutral
ultimately even if it doesn't feel that
way
on some level at least for the purposes
of approaching stuff but you know look
at the end of the day it's just a lot of
rejection it's the nature of it so I had
that turned out a probably a thousand to
one for the times that I would audition
or more and it wasn't always consistent
the reasons why but all you knew was
that you weren't getting a chance to
participate and so you would have to go
back to the lab and try to get to a
place of being more and more undeniable
and when you are going through all these
rejections of course at a certain point
it just becomes second nature to not
flinch as much when you get turned down
for something but if you were giving
advice to say an up-and-coming actor who
has some degree of talent but is getting
rejected and they're they're really just
feeling like they're getting punched in
the face by the world what would you say
to that person well I think I look at it
mathematically at a certain point which
was I I started just focusing my entire
day on perfecting my craft so I was
either watching a movie reading a book
on stuff doing monologues taking classes
and I bring products from infomercial
ordering products / infomercial came
later that was the dessert that was a
treat for her I got a chance to work but
I would deny myself other things I
couldn't go do this I couldn't
travel until I earned it so I would deny
myself certain things that I would want
to do and say haven't earned that yet
which I find to be a good motivator and
then what I did was if I would screen
test for a movie that was a big
opportunity that would have been
life-changing it would have given me an
opportunity
what do you screen testing I was greater
than idiot I'll ask screen test would be
your clothes there's a couple people for
a role and now they're going to film a
scene from the movie with you and
perhaps the already casted actor or just
pair of people together and then screen
testing they would just see who mixes
and matches or how do you do on camera
how do they feel you come off and I had
a couple of those maybe four or five
four good opportunities and when you
don't get it so you could go through
seven or eight auditions to get to this
point is between you and two or three
other people and when you don't get it
your day the next day doesn't change
meaning you still are going to get asked
to go in for five lines on a television
show or something smaller there is no
advancement as far as opportunity you
you were just a person with the same
credits you had so there was a lot of
time spent to get to that and energy to
get to that moment and if it didn't pan
out there was no change in how somewhat
you were no more castable as a known
entity than what you were so what would
happen is when you would get that close
and it wouldn't happen at first I would
get down and I would take four or five
days and I would just not do anything
and I'd say oh this is lose my energy
and then I started to realize that the
week I took off was really two weeks
that it was a week of not getting better
and it was a week of getting worse and I
said now I've given myself two weeks
less to improve that the things I'm in
control of and I started looking at it
like a percentage game the more I worked
on things my percentages would go up and
what I realized later was it gave you a
confidence to feel like you belong there
it gave you permission to perform in
situations that didn't feel comfortable
because you had felt good about what you
had brought to the table and so I would
suggest that you find a process where
are able to I think it's important to
allow yourself to feel disappointed I
think it's important that you don't turn
off those feelings but it is also
important to how do you do that as
quickly as possible
did then become a productive again and
start doing the things that are going to
give you a better opportunity for what
you want the same could be said for a
relationship it hurts your feelings is
but how much time is defective in
mourning and processing it I really
believe no time is not good you need
that moment to accept it but the sooner
you can get back to doing things for
your own growth and the things you're in
charge of I think your chances of having
the things you want in your life become
greater I think also from what I've
observed in you and other people you've
done really well in their respective
fields is that having an opportunity to
be exposed to micro failures in some
environment like wrestling like
auditions inoculates you in such a way
that you develop a tolerance for
rejection and that allows you to
capitalize on opportunities much more
effectively later because you don't take
the two weeks off and correct and it
allows you to improve so but then we
have the problem the other side which I
don't know if you've experienced you see
it with boxers a lot but once you have a
level of success can you maintain a
motivation right to have the approach
that you once had right when the
immediate needs are not there as strong
or have you done with that so you're in
a place right now that I find yeah I
suppose I've taken what was a liability
or what I viewed as a weakness for a
long time meaning an ADHD like scattered
attention where I would move from
interest to interest I would get very
hot on something than very Coleman shift
interest my viewed that as a bad thing
being a jack-of-all-trades master of
none and at some point asked myself what
if I turned what if this weakness could
be a strength you know what if this bug
could be a feature how would I describe
it it was like okay you know if I could
make a career as a professional
dilettante what would that look like and
by doing that I allow myself this sort
of intravenous hit of excitement even
though on a macro level my
career has has improved over time I'm
continually becoming a novice some
extents told I'm always going back to
white belt and I think that gives me a
certain hunger that allows me to be both
excited and also not get too inflated a
head any bigger than it already is
so in something like a podcast which is
the continuation of the same thing
although you're exploring different
people
yeah how do you stay is it that the the
people are different and these
opportunity to investigate is different
but how do you stay focused on that
knowing that your nature is - yeah so
the pub the podcast has been an anomaly
I thought I would maybe do six or ten
episodes and be the way I choose
projects and I think this is in some
respects pretty similar to how you look
at a lot of things but I will ask myself
which of these say five projects will
allow me to develop new skills and
relationships
that could last beyond the project even
if it even if it fails and that was the
goal with the podcast so I wanted to
format it in such a way work on in such
a way that I could for instance listen
to audio and get rid of really annoying
verbal tics that I had like using the
word pretty good pretty interesting
pretty this pretty that I use that
adverb is this throw away for everything
I drove me insane but I didn't realized
I listened to my own audio and the short
answer is and I think we'll we have
actually a good clip to elaborate on
this a bit is scratching my own itch so
for each of the podcast yet I have on
because I have an intense personal
interest something they're good at or
figured out where I feel I am weak or
weaker so if I'm having say relationship
issues and having trouble thinking
through them all goes to an ester Pro if
I'm having some type of a weight
training issue and I want to get
stronger I might go to like the Charles
Poliquin or Apollo to learn and it's an
intensely personal interest for me that
drives each of the guests and that gives
me the variety within something it could
be viewed as as uniform I'm going to ask
you about how swingers came to be
because it seems to tie into frustration
but first how much of that was
word-for-word script how much of that
was improv well I was in a lot of that
was improv and it's in the moment we had
a production crew we did that movie for
$250,000 and I think our sound guy
normally had done porno movies and you
know we were doing this stuff and taking
it and I think they were judging us a
lot like oh these [ __ ] guys saying
money again and so when I did that I
looked I caught I think a crew member
that was maybe like like snoozefest it
was late and so I used it as if it was
patrons at the bar and I responded in
the moment as if like I'm the [ __ ]
[ __ ] for trying right like I'm the
[ __ ] [ __ ] on the place for
celebrating my friends gross right so it
was a but it was all connected it was
the intention was obviously there and
then you would play around with this and
how did how did swingers come to be and
of course I'm sure there are many many
different aspects to it but why did that
movie happen well there's a yeah I think
everyone remembers I think whatever you
work on a movie people always remember
their contributions greater in success
and failure people always make it like
that I've tried to warn them right but
swingers really came about because there
was an auditioning for lots of parts
that I felt weren't truthful or
connected to what was going on there was
not they were being written that's why I
think it's important for young people
both musically and writing wise whether
it's film or books or whatever to have a
voice because it's unique to the culture
at that time and I think things that
resonate in the culture are more
important than a lot setting out for a
large global thing I think is I think
sometimes you can have things become
larger but if it starts whether it's
boys in the hood or something that feels
like it's trying to explore the now is
very viable superstar that's - and all
the biggest startups if you'll recognize
here almost all those started with that
right a need it's the same thing that he
was saying a frustration there is
something so it felt like for me I had
lived in most feel as the old punk rock
bands started playing live swing music
and writing original swing music I had
always had a interest in old swing music
and big band news
and country music and I still listen to
it when I was older and so when this
kind of came about you could go to a
live venue in here original song by a 14
piece band it was fantastic and it was
just what was going on it was nothing we
created it was the environment which we
lived in which to your point what starts
with you you're seeing a need and the
cause and right so I said to John I said
that we can't sit around and wait for
someone to write something you know we
should go write something and I started
my journey I write something in two
weeks John had this story inside of him
which was leaving a girl from behind and
moving to this unique world and be sort
of being a guy that showed him around to
these bars in these places and we became
focused on getting that ruby made we had
nothing really he had an agent I didn't
but we would go and sit in this coffee
shop the one that was in the movie and
in our minds we would play out it was
almost like visualisation we would play
out how to get past obstacles how would
be received I think this is interesting
in life you mean obstacles to making
getting meeting the movie made and at
the time we had read the book The
Fountainhead which is you know the I had
written earlier John had read it which
is defiant and it's a pursuit of one's
artistic goals meaning you don't
compromise you you stay truthful to what
you're exploring and so we were very
young and very much wanting to not
change things there were suggestions to
make the movie if there was a girl that
was part of the group because they
wanted to hear a girl's perspective and
I thought if these guys had a girl's
perspective they wouldn't act this way
you know this is about this is about
young men when you're outside of high
school or college for the first time how
do you go up and meet someone when you
don't have a comfort zone with them you
know so it was really exploring that
time it was counter it wasn't a health
video it was more what was going on so
we were rejecting of these things in any
way and we finally the Glandon came on
to direct the movie there was a journey
for us to play the parts which ended up
happening but I a director come on just
to finance the movie we couldn't get the
movie made there was lots of used to do
live readings and every time we do a
reading it played huge but and the way
that they would handicap things they
would suggest what's the audience for it
there's a problem in Hollywood in that
it's gone so Wall Street inning
it's Oh quarterly everyone needs to
drive towards the return it's like the
car industry it used to be an engineer
would get the corner office and it's the
Harvard guys get the office if the
finance dies you know which but the
productivity of the cars perhaps suffer
sometimes and in our industry you know
it's the IP that's going to break
through but that can be challenging when
there's a cultural things that are
trying to break through and that they
can a lot of times they resonate as
people connecting to self growth you
know the stages of one's life whether
it's in a Campbell way or call young
ways the same evolution of facing your
Furies and the nature of letting go of
ego and those things and the stories are
exploring those in some way so we dug
came on he had the money to make the
movie he directed it he actually shot it
was a scimitar fur and I think it was a
perfect combination there was conflict
at the time but I think if he would have
changed any of those elements you
wouldn't have had what you had Doug
brought a great he had not hung out
these neighborhoods were been to Vegas
in these ways and he did a great job
with the camera it felt documentary
style as if you were there and it became
a key ingredient and a way to receive a
movie like this John did a phenomenal
job of taking something personal and
putting in a structure and drawing on
the things around him and I think it was
like a band where it just worked so it
was pure it was something that we were
passionate about it was from our lives
our childhood and it was exaggerated
with an awareness obviously for comedy
but it truly is sort of about in this
case it's letting go of rejection of a
girl and giving yourself permission to
feel like you're viable that someone
could love you for if you start off
saying how do I learn tricks to trick
someone and at the core of that is
suggesting that you yourself would be
loved right that you it would have to be
some manipulation which is such a
terrible place to work from I think what
made swingers so different than a lot of
a pick up stuff later was swingers was
really kind of self empowering you know
it he rejects Trent's stuff sort of in
the end he
and next to someone by being his true
self he doesn't try to be something
different and it's through going inward
and finding his way that he evolves to
his next stage which is now he's
connecting someone from a truthful place
and so it was to the point that you
showed with the equipment Blake it was a
frustration and what was available and
then where are the stories from our age
and the motivation to to create those
were there any points where you felt the
movie wasn't going to get made or you
doubted oh god it was every day we felt
there was money was an arms dealer at
some point that was going to invest I
don't know okay I'm not getting hold on
oh no I don't really take meetings that
we take me to the agency and talk they
don't we not want to win it doesn't rule
D and whatever but then we'd leave in
the AG village they're an arms dealer I
think I don't know but here's the point
they're going to give you a check I
don't know so but none of them came
through until finally dug it made the
movie and you need Doug Pryor I did not
know Doug I met him through John but I
think everyone how did you guys convince
him to do it I think he came to a
read-through a friend of his suggested
the script that he saw the value of it
and wanted to participate yeah and so
there was if there was times we made the
movie wanting to go to film festivals in
this case Sundance was real popular and
that we got rejected by Sundance and the
mission was sort of to get into Sundance
and it felt to me that perhaps the the
male point of view in the unapologetic
way that was very authentic to what
these guys journey was was not in sync
necessarily with what the festival was
doing so or if that is the movie so it
was interesting to have had as part of
our plan be given an O and that was
another resilient moment but at that
point it's like Dorothy right you had to
not put a value on the wizard and go
within again and say well why am I
telling this and why do I believe it was
forcing us to reaffirm approach the Edit
even from a greater strength of truth of
prediction of what we were doing
and ultimately it became what it became
I like to say that we knew it but we
were naive enough to believe that if we
were we experienced this we found a
value in it and it just so turned out
that there was lots of people maybe not
living in a swing centric neighborhood
you know as like the people would be the
script they would say why can't you put
in grunge music or you know hip-hop
music or things that were popular to
suggest that an audience would be more
engaging but we said no it's not
interesting to us this is a unique
community and I think the uniqueness is
actually what made it translate and then
swing music became how to surgeons
afterwards but I think by not
overthinking what people want by
experiencing in the same way that he's
saying realizing from a personal place
where you're frustrated about or what
you feel like there's lacking sometimes
that is a great catalyst to creating
that very niche thing you know and then
it gets into the fabric in a very
different way well I think also that as
soon as you start designing something
for an audience this has certainly been
advice I've received from successful
writers you stop looking at your own
pain you stop looking at your own needs
and you start making something for an
imaginary figure in your head and you
start veering away from a place of
honesty where you know something is
concrete and if I look at for instance
but then you're putting satisfaction in
someone else's hands which is very
dangerous versus did you attain what
your goals were knowing that your goals
might change and I say goes I don't mean
perception or results I mean the
execution sure which goes back to the
schooling and learning in the same way
for me
am i exploring what I believe in versus
trying to please someone definitely now
I left Kurt Vonnegut let their registers
knees talked about this a lot I want to
give a few others you tube thing with
the fall rise story it's great he
explains the stories and kind of a fall
rise which would be Cinderella and he
does a real nonchalant I recommend it
there are a few other examples of this I
think in your career and you've such a
filmography we can't possibly go through
all of them
you mentioned music so I want to ask I
just a fact-checking question which is
later of course you period Jurassic Park
did you come on Steven Spielberg's radar
because the jaws theme music was in
swingers yes and you needed clearance
that's incredible yeah it was odd but I
had never hunger I was real defiant and
what I wanted to do and but I love
Spielberg's movies and went into a
Jurassic Park and did that and then
really liked him I found him to be very
generous with his knowledge he took
meetings he would talk about western
movies I'm a fan of westerns and we
would just sit as two fans and
dissecting things and I found him which
i think is very nice and someone in his
position allowing my opinions and taking
the men and turning them around and then
coming back I felt it was a playful and
I found him as a person that was uh
obviously knowledgeable to still be
including in a young man's conversations
in film and that was a great quality of
his that I think was um I enjoyed that
connection in those conversations with
what else did you of course you've
learned a lot from observing people on
stage saying improv and elsewhere what
else did you pick up from spill burger
learn from him well that was really you
know that movie really that was my
biggest thing was his ability to
create a separation - nobody wanted but
at the same time be engaging with others
and yeah I just admired the tone in
which he did that and that was in just a
very open-minded tone or with its
confidence and that it was not pushing
down to others right was his where
though I think he would ultimately make
his decisions but without the imposing
bread or the struggle of it given that
the most frequent question from my fans
on Twitter and Facebook was something
related to speed or comfort we have to
watch clip from wedding crashers the
reason I wanted to show that just aside
from just shits and giggles I want to
show it that became at the time the
highest-grossing r-rated film of all
time and I've heard about conversations
of earning the rating and why do you
think that film did so well I think we
work from a similar place of swingers at
the time I had rejected mode after
Jurassic Park I didn't do a lot of
studio movies and I just I was offered
some but I was just more gravitating
towards if he's independent movies and
then we've gotten and then when Todd
Phillips who still a friend who I like
quite a bit Todd offered me old school
the studio said I don't we don't think
he can be funny kid done mainly dramatic
stuff younger and an old school felt
like a great thing to me because I felt
like we were doing something authentic
but I also could really excuse-me buy
into it in a way that felt like this is
awesome this is fun and so I sort of got
my wings in a way that I could do more
commercial fear but it was going to be
something that I was really excited
about so we got to do Crashers there was
a concept an idea
the director David Dobkin I had done
this movie clay pigeons with young girl
I liked him quite a bit but Owen is a
terrific writer I mean he wrote a lot of
Wes Anderson stuff with West younger and
he just very has a very interesting take
on things
we have similarities and differences but
we just approached it and started to
just write like in the course of a month
like we just sort of changed the
structure and the writing of the script
with the director we all just would sit
and write and change it so very much so
in the spirit that you and your friends
would do something not worrying whether
it was going to be light not worrying
whether the studio would say was okay
and I remember first being on the set
saying some of the things I was saying
and I was like I can't believe no one's
stopping or no one's saying you can't
say this but I think the difference here
was we weren't earning or our I had no
intention of being shocking for shocking
sake if you look at that theme you go
back to the early statement that there's
nothing funny about comedy I think what
makes that thing interesting as funny as
he is has absolute unapologetic
convictions about some things that might
contradict each other and his point of
view is surprising so he is infuriated
that he was jacked off under the table
he blames his friend for putting him in
the circumstances right like that would
be a terrible moment that happened by a
very attractive younger girl but in his
mind this is a horror that no one should
should have and yet at the same time an
older woman's breast to fondle them
would be absolute list that would be joy
and that would be an exceptional moment
and then he kind of puts himself in that
moment like a child like an already like
sense-memory right like in his mind what
he build it up as and so I think the
commitment to those points of view and
how they lay up against each other and
then the team players like you're
mocking the very concept of like what
the healthy work environment yeah and
yet it's applying very much so to sexual
encounters in the house so my point
being that I think we really just try to
define dysfunction friendship that
feeling of you love someone a lot of a
friendship but you like a married couple
you have real issues and problems and
they conflict and we were only looking
to pursue this and I didn't know that it
would make money or what do we do there
wasn't a lot of you know there was some
are movies that had done well old school
did good and then of course it was
something
arian of course the stuff we grew up on
or I'm aging you more than me but you
know that the animal house and these
things that was again of that time we
were really just looking to hit the
guitar chords in an honest way for what
we found to be fun and then it turned
out to be a larger success so you've had
many different milestones and landmarks
throughout your career to them I think
you're certainly swingers wedding
crashers the next clip I'd like to show
and then I have a question about all
three is the breakup so this movie was
very successful what do you think made
it different well I had an idea I had
never done a romantic comedy and then I
asked her that I fell into the cappings
of some of these and there was a lot of
good in the approach to this movie and
one thing that I should have held
stronger to but to that point was I had
I was off of these romantic comedies and
it wasn't my life experience I found
that like a lot of people of my
generation and I think maybe with
evaluation too strongly I was really
committed to focus on my career and that
a relationship was something that you
could be in love or have feelings but
you had to get yourself into a certain
place career-wise which is just not
necessarily always the case or true but
at that time I had never thought about
what would make a marriage work or being
with someone but I would you know have
feelings and investigation and be with
people but I was fascinated by because I
had this experience happen where you
could be really drawn to someone and
very much connected to them and not just
physically but there was something going
on where you were really drawn to them
and at the same time there was things
about them that were very much so in
conflict with things about yourself it
was it was not a match
and there was always lessons I would
look at it more in a spiritual way or
conscious way or psychology way what is
it that's playing out in this way so I
thought sometimes you have to really
love someone your skill sets not there
there's isn't there
and so you clash
you burn out the relationship you burn
out the love and now you can never
return to it you've damaged it to the
point where there's no going back and
now you're a better person if you were
to meet today you'd have a chance but
you can't meet today and you're not
going to be with that person and there
was an oddity in that moment to me I
love this person enough to stick around
and learn this lesson and now I can't go
forward with them and it was more
authentic to me and my experience at the
time that you don't end up with someone
you love a lot because of your flaws but
at best you could learn and be a better
person and then go out there meet a
person again knowing that in life
sometimes the love you feel younger as
strong as it is it doesn't return in the
same ways because you've gone through
that experience you felt those rushes
before so it's an interesting
interesting journey so in that movie I
wanted them not to end up together and I
had two great young writers they had
done a lot Jeremy Gerlich and Jay
lavender I had this concept I want to do
something in Chicago because I was from
the area and I wanted to set up this Odd
Couple in an apartment that you would
see their flaws and differences and you
know underneath it see the hurt like the
scene at the door that precedes it he
wants to go in it's not that he's absent
a feeling and he doesn't know how and
he's too afraid and played that out in
the way that's comedic but dysfunctional
and totally different you know it wasn't
a traditional comedy throughout you know
kind of reversing the first half being
heavy and then being like and getting
what you wanted so that was the that was
the intention and I think again maybe
the the why of it which i think is what
people respond to was I was personally
interested in understanding when you
destroy someone you love a relationship
with someone you love
you know what is the dynamics and
leaving they both leave in a better
place but there's a nostalgia that not
for us not for this moment
it's the reason I wanted to show these
three clips specifically and talk about
some of the earlier cold-calling
and someone is that what I found so
reassuring and also tactically practical
looking at your career is number one you
don't get in life what you deserve you
get way to negotiate so you should be
you should become good at negotiating
whether that's having the luck or
misfortune to have certain becomes say
that put you up on phones or just
reading books like getting past now so
you could spare our negotiating there
are a number of decent ones that the
point number one point number two is
that a on a very reassuring note you
don't have to be what many people
conceive of as or let me rephrase this
you don't have to create brand new
worlds that are utterly different from
the one we lived in to create something
unique and successful when I look at
some of the most important creative
decisions you've made the projects that
you've selected they have they appear to
have two things in common one is you're
scratching your own itch I mean you've
turned down I know this from
conversations to you I mean a lot of
very where people would consider
lucrative opportunities to focus on
things that you personally want to do to
satisfy some need or want of your own
and secondly that you can be or be seen
as very very original by simply being
honest and having the voice and I don't
mean that in a cliched way I mean that
if you simply tell the story of a bunch
of dudes who are completely
irresponsible on many levels being dudes
say in the case of wedding crashers
because that hasn't been
seit old and very unfiltered way just by
definition you've done something very
very unique they can stand on its own
there and then let's say break up having
the ending you wouldn't expect and all
of these issues that are conversations
that probably everyone in this room has
had at some point or another you can in
fact create something that is not only
successful but original because of that
and I remember early on being told
because having so much trouble writing
my first book and I would read I would
draft a few chapters they'd be kind of
slapstick stupid Three Stooges because I
thought I was supposed to be funny then
I'd throw it out and then I tried to do
something serious and be really pedantic
and boring and I throw it out and one of
my friends said it's not that hard to
have a voice you just have to be
honestly yourself I can brace your weird
self and display that and then you're
consistent and then you are so the one
and only version of yourself that you
can be yeah that's a journey that we all
learn of tone Mel Gibson who's one of my
favorite filmmakers and I worked with
him on hacksaw and without knowing at
the old Warner Brothers when it was a
family they had a mission statement for
their movies that was slightly different
but it was entertain educate and the Mel
would say elevate so if you just
entertain people you keep it fun and
engaging educator learning about
something right to the course of the
movie and elevate you leave feeling
inspired that you could do something and
wonder thing was enlightening but
similar is a road map and I think that's
important like and going to do dramatic
stuff like it doesn't have to be the
dark keys of the piano always an
earnestness if you'll false in a way so
I think being able to be light or have
fun in writing and then when you want to
make a point or have it hit you give
yourself permission it feels like to to
go within and go within and out towns so
I want to just in the time we have left
just a whole lot just a few minutes ask
a few questions that I like to ask
everyone I interview and I don't think
I've asked any of these of you
personally when we've been talking about
marcella teens and so on before I are
there any particular books that stand
out for you as favorite books or books
at youth
re-read or gifted to other people
Benjamin Franklin's autobiography is I
think the most compelling of books and
that he's very right so I think
originally to his son it's not his
biography is his telling of it and was
such a prolific person and I think
what's interesting in similar ways that
I enjoy you and what you do he talks
about his process he invented the pros
and cons list the Public Library the
fire department and was very prolific in
science obviously electricity the
catheter bifocals you know flippers but
then musically he in languages he spoke
many languages is a falsity that you're
one side of your mind or the other they
really are connected and he would
explore process very much so about it's
like in language learning Italian he had
a chess opponent that was very equal so
they would play in the loser the winner
got to assign a very rigorous homework
assignment on the language so in force
you to really stay focused on chess and
then if he lost you were actually
learning something that was valuable so
just systems and things that he would do
and how he would approach things where
he would be somewhat vulnerable so it
was encouraging that a process could
lead to changing your circumstance so
that makes perfect sense to me because
I've heard stories don't know if they're
true about early days in LA when you
make calls to prospective agents and
you'd say I mean I'm visiting town I
want to weigh all my options before
making a decision and you had a way of
presenting yourself in such a way that
would hopefully become a self-fulfilling
prophecy which i think is very useful I
think it's a very valuable strategy and
makes me think of I read that this in
Walter Isaacson's biography of Franklin
but he made his real money in printing
right as you know and one thing that he
used to do even though he was he had
employees and everything was under
control as he would get a barrel and
fill it full of all of these like print
supplies and walk up and down the street
and then go back in like take your rest
drink his tea because he wanted everyone
around to see how busy and successful
Ben Franklin the paper right to to the
propagate more business which in fact
worked so that makes I think that's
important skill set is calling people
that you're not comfortable with and
getting access and figuring out how to
do that if you don't learn how to reach
out you've given yourself permission
many times prior to even writing what
you would call someone because you were
fascinated in it you'd be surprised if
done in a way that feels good how people
are willing to sit because they're doing
these things a lot of times they're
engaged in process themselves well I
used to teacher used to teach a class in
high tech entrepreneurship and and I was
assigned as a as a prize a round-trip
ticket anywhere in the world to the
student in the class who could get a
hold of and get a response from the most
difficult to reach a person we had
people get responses from horn Buffett
for former presidents it was amazing and
I've even heard of some people so you
don't need a class to do this but you
can put together a betting pool with a
group of friends say alright everyone's
going to put in 100 200 bucks whatever
is enough to like staying if you lose it
a little bit and then compete to get a
response from the hardest to reach
person go back to Frankel to the Juno
you know he would have the club where
people would get together and they would
do similar types of things so it's a
skill you know it's something to
definitely work on because and nowadays
I think with the internet and stuff we
all have so much wealth of just
information it used to be so hard to get
a book now you can get information on
anything so I think getting information
is interesting but getting the skill
sets like active literacy being able to
extend up and give a speech being able
to write your ideas I think those are
all things that are good to spend time
on because whatever your passion
so they'll help you in that is it
ultimately you may need to connect or
get a job or do something and that
skillsets helpful well I might be missed
at repeating this kind of like every
internet quote is attributed to Abraham
Lincoln but I remember hearing this
relates to maybe a separate podcast we
can have on education your thoughts on
that but at one point I want to say
Henry Ford is being interviewed and the
interviewer asked him some factual
question and you jumped you didn't know
the answer and the interviewer somewhat
condescendingly set up any fifth graders
memorized that fact and he said that's
why I have a library so I don't have to
memorize facts but I know where to find
them and I think that in lieu of a
library sure you have the Internet but
even more valuable when you develop the
ability to reach out to people and have
conversations and make you uncomfortable
uncomfortable and expand that sphere of
comfort you can find any information
that you from the horse's mouth right
and I think but seeing someone like
yourself
it gives permission to feel like you
could do it because I see someone who
starts from a place of being drowned by
a bully and emotionally you connect to
that your you know putting a sense of
memory with a terrible experience to
then realize that whatever my personal
dialogue is about seeing how it goes you
know one great thing about failure is
you realize it's not as bad as your mind
makes it out to be it script the fear is
more crippling than the actual
consequences
the consequence is a lot of times you're
almost relieving in a way because now
you've faced it you've gone through it
and that kind of takes that away from ya
know it's amazing how also over time the
more you you don't address your fear and
meaning if you take some large fear and
you break it down into the smallest
possible steps let's say for swimming
for me is even just putting my face
underwater for a period of time right so
forget about swimming we're going about
learning how to breathe just putting
your face underwater and then when you
finally have the incentive like this bet
that I had with my friend or rather this
mutually assigned year's resolution with
a deadline was up with a deadline yeah
with the deadline when I actually sat
down and found a method of swimming
called total immersion which I recommend
everybody which was introduced to me by
Chris Sacca
who also had difficulty swimming he said
I've the answer your prayers it took me
a week about ten days to go from zero
laps and up world to like 40 laps of
workout as meditation it was incredibly
it wasn't it was incredibly easy
compared to the mental monster that I
had created for myself that's what's
fascinating is how much of it is the
woods that we've created yeah versus the
actual path to the destination so if you
had a billboard this is more metaphor
than anything else but you could put
anything on a gigantic billboard to get
a message out to millions of people what
would it be I probably wouldn't say
anything because I don't like to give
advice to people because I I feel like
you can show people the way but that
they have to find their own way but
maybe it would be to learn how you learn
and to learn yourself you know and
accept yourself learn who you are
and learn to accept and love yourself I
think is a big part of life because
within that you might find your interest
and explore give yourself permission to
explore like the Campbell quo to follow
your bliss or and then also learning how
you learn is getting quiet and learning
how to engage in things for example your
swimming situation finding a way to
approach it where you are going to enjoy
it and versus taking some sort of a
course that someone says you have to do
it this way there's always more than one
way to the waterfall I'll be a long
billboard
could this be a mirror is there anything
it just in closing any recommendation or
ask of the people in this room or the
people listening to this for the
audience any recommendation asked or
otherwise it like as as parting words
parting words oh man I I don't know I
just feel that you know being engaged in
life is a good thing and trying it stuff
is a good thing and then really doing
your own evaluations for what how you
feel about what you're doing is
important and I think connecting with
people is good and laughing and having
downtime and taking the pressure off and
just be daydreaming you know being
present not not always driving towards
something sometimes I think learning
comes from letting the mind rest and
doing nothing as well one thing I've
really observed from you that touches on
a lot of those checkboxes is many of
your interactions I've seen it with me
and others is if you want to be
interesting be interested you ask a lot
of questions so maybe focus on holding
forth and holding court less and asking
more and better questions I think you're
dilated version of it yes you know be
engaged in learning from others and
watching that for sure more than feeling
a need to pose where you're at now well
then I personally as well thank you for
helping to make fearless a reality
I want to thank you truly and for coming
in and playing I think you do a
tremendous job and there's been a lot of
good that have come into my life what
you do and I know to others as well and
I hope that continues so thank you for
your inspiration and for your
vulnerability I appreciate it ladies
until then VIP on
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday is that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that have somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by trunk club
there are two types of men out there you
know who you are guys you love shopping
for clothes but are short on time
category a and those of you who hate it
category B I am in the latter category
my fashion sense is also probably
somewhere between homeless and confused
with a dash of lazy added in either way
you can take art and I've used trunk
club now and have found some of my
favorite pieces of clothing that make me
look a lot better than I'll be able to
handle on my own and there are many
reasons for that but you can get
clothing that fits perfectly and looks
amazing without ever stepping into a
store again thanks to trunk club and
they make it very very easy and the
clothing is handpicked by a personal
stylist your own personal stylist all
you do is go to Trump Club calm
forward-slash Tim type in your
measurements share your likes and
dislikes they'll pick your clothes from
more than 80 top brands and ship them
right to your door you keep what you
like you send back what you don't if you
don't like any of it send it all back it
doesn't matter
and trunk club is not a subscription
service this is what appealed to me
among many other things I didn't want to
constantly be getting dinged by things
or have to deal with the headache of
constantly getting boxes it's not a
subscription service shipping is always
free then you have five days to try on
the clothes so a couple points here
number one get started today go to Trump
Club calm 4/10 try it out you get
premium clothes expert advice no work no
risk that is a winning combo and I have
found some of my favorite espadrilles
choose from them bright green I do like
to color green and they actually work
I've had so many compliments on these
shoes and more people ask me where I got
them any other pair of shoes I've ever
had and more shirts I kept ended up
keeping about I would say three quarters
in my box which I did not expect to do
so go to trunk club comm forward slash
Tim and check it out this episode is
brought to you by 99designs I've used
99designs for years for all sorts of
graphic design needs whether you need a
logo website cover anything else
99designs was created to make great
designs accessible to everyone to make
the process of getting designs much much
easier so when I first started out for
instance testing prototypes covers and
getting prototype covers from for our
body
I want the contest route that is one
option this is a great solution for
looking for fast affordable design work
and the ability to choose from dozens of
options risk-free let's say you need
something late night quick turnaround
well people in other time zones other
countries can also help you solve them
from since then I've worked with ninety
ninety designs on a separate path or a
different option and that is the one to
one project service so in a number of
cases and I'll give you one example when
I wanted to create the cover for my
audio book The Tao of Seneca this was a
very important project to me I decided
to use their one-to-one project service
and with this service you can invite a
specific designer to your project agree
on a price and then work together until
you're satisfied mail is iterate provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
something incredibly good really some of
the best illustrations I've ever seen
from using this one-to-one project
service with a handful of different
designers and illustrators they blew my
mind 99 designs makes this all very easy
and efficient so you can check out the
towel of Seneca design and other work
that I and your fellow listeners for
that matter have done on 99 designs at
99 designs comm forward slash Tim and
right now you can get a free nhanh Yan
dollar upgrade on your first design
again that's 99 designs com4 slash Tim
[Applause]